the most fundamental idea at the heart of modern
Psychotherapy is that in order to heal ourselves
from our neuroses in the present we've got
to understand what went on in our childhoods
though this thesis makes impeccable theoretical
sense there's one enormous problem with it Amnesia
simply put almost no adult remembers a single
thing that happened to them before they were three
years old countless days and nights a succession
of complicated moods Sensations and events will
have vanished Into Thin Air like a library of
precious books that sent up in smoke or dumped
unceremoniously into the sea furthermore most of
us remember very little of what went on before we
were seven this may seem like an obvious point but
it has momentous implications a period that we've
identified as extremely important is also going to
be entirely nebulous another basic fact of every
childhood is that even though the past may have
been extremely strange and regrettable it will
also in key ways now seem rather normal and Beyond
easy analysis or questioning our childhood is
quite literally what we've grown up with and as we
know what's always been around has a habit of not
signaling its Oddity we might sense that something
was peculiar around our caregivers but to really
get a proper understanding of what these people
were up to tends to be far beyond our ordinary
Powers we prefer to think of something else and
to run fast in an opposite direction this fixes us
in a conundrum which entrenches our neuroses but
there is one extremely useful way to make progress
we should look at ourselves in the present and
start asking ourselves questions everything we
need to know about the past is actually contained
in what's going on for us right now we don't need
to try to remember all sorts of things that have
in reality escaped our memories totally we just
need to check in on who we are today the legacy
of the past will be active rich and vibrant for
better and for worse at every moment of our actual
adult lives so one of the first questions we need
to ask ourselves as archaeologists of our past
is what day to day in the adult world we are
afraid of let's imagine a list of someone who is
asked to complete the sentence I am terrified of
I'm terrified of being thought an idiot of being
found ugly and unacceptable of being humiliated
mocked and rejected I'm scared that people will
be extremely nasty to me now what we dread at the
hands of everyone we meet nowadays is inevitably
going to be a version of what we once feared
at the hands of very specific caregivers in a
very specific and yet very forgotten childhood
this gives us a huge amount to go on indeed
it offers us nothing less than the tools for
our recovery it means that we can take our list
as an archaeological map to guide our thinking
self-questioning might go like this someone
terrified you of being an idiot so who might it
have been and how did that happen someone found
you ugly and unacceptable so what might have
occurred here someone has it seems arbitrarily
humiliated mocked and rejected you does that ring
any bells someone probably gave you an experience
of extreme nastiness is this somehow familiar
though we might not be used to thinking in this
way with such prompts at hand Rich and vibrant
thoughts may rise up from the unconscious we might
get a new perspective on our caregivers and on
what we underwent framed in this way we might see
with Newfound Clarity that quite a lot more was
going on in those early days than we generally
like to imagine the what will be the next step
we'll need to go back over the past with a lot
of patience and courage while also bearing in
mind that what we've been projecting willy-nilly
onto every man and woman in the present and every
difficulty we face in the here and now actually
had very particular Origins which the more we
understand them the more we will feel liberated
and unburdened our future won't have to feel so
constantly difficult or fear Laden once we can
trace back its real difficulties to a point of
origin a Psychotherapy is always insisted and
promised remembering truly will set us free
if you liked this film you can download our
app just follow the link on your screen now